how many people know what automatic
differentiation is okay a couple ads how
many people have heard of deep learning
okay that's good all right it'd be
disappointing if you hadn't heard of
that because that's kind of the least
partially the motivation for thinking
about this stuff today
so what I'm going to tell you about I
should say first I kind of wear two hats
in some ways so I'm here at Twitter
full-time and we've just founded a group
called the advanced technologies group
the but I'm also a professor at Harvard
and I lead the Harvard intelligent
probabilistic systems group where we
study AI machine learning and comput a
tional statistics and things like that
so I'm gonna tell you about things are
actually a little bit of a blend of both
stuff at Twitter and stuff at Harvard
but with this common theme of thinking
about automatic differentiation always
kind of like titles that are sort of
like imperative statements you should do
this thing and you should be using
automatic differentiation I'm gonna tell
you what it is and why it's it's
interesting you're probably you may be
already using it without really
realizing it but first I kind of want to
set the stage a little bit we do a lot
of different kinds of machine learning
across a lot of teams at Twitter doing
lots of the things you kind of imagine
and maybe some things you haven't
thought about you know from ranking the
time line trying to find the kind of
content that you're most interested in
trying to find the the people that you
might be most interested in following if
use periscope you know trying to surface
the the best content trying to to you
know help it help it be a better
experience for for you individually of
course that internet companies we like
to choose what ads to show you based on
expected you and things like that and
that has a lot of machine learning
behind the scenes and then we also of
course think about safety here it's
where you know how to how to maybe make
it harder to find content that seems
objectionable or identify when people
are spamming and performing abuse and
things like that and some of this is an
increasing amount I would say of this is
is based on deep learning so a lot of
different things whether it's text
thinking about you know what people are
talking about in terms of sentiment or
what people are talking about in terms
of content
or when they're being again abusive or
spammy and of course on Twitter more and
more of what's going on is people
posting interesting images and so
content understanding visual me
understanding is a big part of what
we're trying to do as well whether it's
things like clustering finding groups to
inform search and content discovery or
whether it's classification and
identification of sensitive content but
also increasingly things like automatic
captioning to help visually impaired
users understand what kind of content
that may be they can't otherwise see and
then another kind of emerging area in
machine learning and computer vision
that's also becoming important here at
Twitter is really thinking about how to
do is how to use deep learning tools to
understand video so there's a couple
different ways we think about video live
video and periscope and of course with
vines and increasingly embedded videos
on on Twitter and we'd like to be able
to understand what's going on and help
you find the best stuff and and really
kind of understand for example you know
live when somebody's turning on their
periscope and it's going to take a live
stream of of themselves say producing
some Safari something you might really
like to tune into or maybe they're you
know maybe they're they're taking a
periscope of their pickup game we're
pushing weights across the floor or
whatever it is that they happen to be
doing if you're interested in people
pushing weights across the floor then
maybe we can help you find that and and
these are kind of you know challenging
semantics semantics understanding
problems so we're doing machine learning
in a lot of different ways and a lot of
different kinds of content some of which
is pretty big and pretty challenging it
I think at the very cutting edge of
what's possible but what I'm gonna talk
about today is a kind of I want to kind
of talk about the big picture of the ml
and how we're able to do a lot of that
what I think is really amazing stuff
here with machine learning while in some
ways actually having kind of relatively
small teams relative to other kind of
companies in the valley to have really
big machine learning efforts and a lot
of the reason for this I think boils
down to really thinking about what it is
that we do when we build a machine
learning based product or when we write
a paper and do some research on machine
learning and I feel like a lot of it
boils down to these three kinds of steps
so the first thing you do is you frame
the problem right you think hard about
what it is that you're trying to solve
maybe you come up with some lost
function you come up you think about
your data come up with an architecture
some right
you know all these kind of usual things
in order to sort of scope and define the
problem then you're gonna do a bunch of
calculus almost certainly I mean most of
machine learning the most machine
learning papers are religious people
taking gradients right and this is
because you write down a problem with
some you know you come up with some way
to measure when your parameters are
gonna be good you're gonna fit to the
data and you're probably gonna throw it
at some optimizer and so you're gonna
need a gradient and if you're going to
need a gradient then you're going to
have to do some calculus right you're
gonna have to take some you have to do
some take some derivatives then once
you've done that then you're gonna spend
a bunch of time twiddling the knobs of
the of this algorithm getting the
regularization right and the batch size
right and all this kind of stuff people
people done this kind of thing all the
fiddling that you have to do yeah so
these are the kind of the steps I feel
like broadly speaking that one has to go
through you actually get something
working enough to tell somebody else
about or put it in production and over
the last couple of years you know we've
been thinking a lot about how to
eliminate some of these steps this third
thing here this tweaking I think we've
made really great progress on this using
methods called Bayesian optimization
that formed the that you know my
research group we've been working on for
several years and then form the basis of
the company wet lab that that I sold to
Twitter last year I'm not gonna talk
about that today but I feel like we kind
of nailed this and there's a lot of
great tools out there for for dealing
with this kind of tweaking that often
previously was kind of black magic the
thing I'm gonna talk about today is
eliminating the second step where being
able to you want to be able to do
machine learning deep learning
interesting stuff without having to know
any calculus which is kind of a nice
place to be you don't want you don't
want to sort of doing the math to get in
the way of solving the problems that you
have to solve not least because it's
sometimes hard you get things wrong and
so I'm gonna tell you about automatic
differentiation which is a way to to go
after this automatically and so then you
get to the point where you know you read
a machine learning paper and most of it
doesn't even need to exist like maybe we
could even sort of you know my goal is
to kind of get to a place where we can
we can put our machine learning papers
into 140 characters right where you just
explain the idea you have it's pretty
clear what that would be you take the
derivatives automatically and then you
automatically tune the the parameters
for this thing so this is this is living
the dream right you
explain your idea it's pretty obvious
that like how another machine learning
algorithm put could put that together
for you the place where this really
comes up I think it's in deep learning
so deep learning is is an amazing
branding rebranding of of neural
networks the neural networks that are
really not that significantly different
than they were at sort of like the early
90s
it's what's really changed in a lot of
ways I mean there's some definitely some
new ideas but but I think the biggest
part that's changed is we have a lot
more data and a lot more compute and we
understand a little bit more about
optimization than we did before
but nevertheless the theory in a sense
of these of these kinds of things that
have been very successful visual object
recognition speech recognition or
informing all kinds of things that we're
interacting with every day the theory
for these things is really is really
lacking it's deep learning is still very
much an empirical science and has
anybody ever seen the movie Billy
Madison as this has dates me like crazy
but the new Billy Madison it's at it's
horrible Adam Sandler movie and he and
his like idiot buddies they go to this
they go to like a like a McDonald's and
they have this game where they they pull
the pickles out of their hamburgers and
they throw them against the window and
they in it and they race and see whose
pickle slides to the bottom first and
this is kind of where deep learning is
people are throwing pickles against the
window they don't really know why that
pickle slides down faster but
nevertheless we're gonna throw a lot of
pickles at the window and see which ones
sort of which ones seemed to work seem
to win the race and and so the key is
how do we throw a lot of pickles at the
window in order to unorder to build
better systems that can use neural
networks okay so that's what automatic
differentiation about is about it's
about doing less calculus and throwing
more pickles and finding better better
deep learning architectures better deep
learning systems and better machine
learning systems more broadly in less
time with less effort so just to kind of
remind you what this what this is all
about so if you've heard a neural
networks and you probably at one point
maybe as an undergrad learned about the
backpropagation algorithm yeah maybe
No okay so back propagation is this kind
of somewhat magical sounding algorithm
that that people used to
neural networks that's been around it's
been reinvented several times most sort
of famously in about 1986 the idea of
back propagation is it's a way to adjust
the weights in a neural network so here
we have a neural network that's like you
know you want to build a cat detector so
you're gonna take an image of a cat and
it goes through parameterised layers of
weights that are implementing little
functions that you're composing together
so the input outputs of one become the
input of the next all the way up until
you get something like a logistic
regression that is labeling something as
being a cat or a dog or a horse or
whatever and what we're trying to do is
tune all these parameters for all these
little functions all these weights and
such a way that when you give it an
image of a cat it tends to give you the
label cat okay so that's the name of the
game the way we train these generally is
you you have what's called a forward
prop forward pass where you actually
compute the current value of the
function and then you're going to
compute its gradient by doing what we
call backward backward propagation or
back prop where you look at the error
that you got at the end and then you
look at what if at how the different
parameters affected that error going
backwards towards the image of the cat
okay
this often seems like kind of a magical
thing where we're back propagating
errors but it really is just the chain
rule it's the chain rule from like high
school calculus alright and and it turns
out that the chain rule is something
that can be applied very directly
programmatically and ordinarily when we
did deep learning we would have to think
really hard about what all the
derivatives were going to be in this
kind of thing and possibly make mistakes
and maybe it didn't work you spent a lot
of time doing math and less time kind of
building the system and now we have
tools that are gonna let you do that
without having to do the math yourself
so automatic differentiation just to be
clear about kind of what it is it's
basically a set of abstractions that you
can use to where you write down sort a
particular function and if that
functions it's differentiable then
you're gonna wind up getting great and
sub it for free like like very easily
you just kind of get these function
handles alongside your alongside your
neural network they're gonna give you
the gradients in addition to the actual
function value it's important to
differentiate this from from like
symbolic differentiation where maybe if
you use something like Mathematica you
write
mathematical expression and convert that
into a new mathematical expression
that's that's it's that it's derivative
it's not that it's also not numeric
approximations we use like finite
differences to compute to compute the
the derivative what it is is a way to
get exact derivatives but very
efficiently sort of storing information
as you go forward that you can then
reuse as you go backwards so to give you
an idea of kind of what I'm actually
talking about here and what this looks
like to use in practice so here's a
little bit of Python code so this is
defining a very simple neural network
you've got some stuff up here where
you're gonna write down a neural network
that's gonna take an input take some
weights and put his X here take some
weights applies a few layers of little
little sort of sigmoid functions and
gives you an output then like in almost
all machine learning algorithms we have
some lost function that takes that thing
and scores how well our parameters are
doing relative to a piece of data and
then we sum that data we sum that score
over all of our data gave it now
ordinarily we would have to write
another function that takes the
derivative of all this stuff and it's
probably wrong okay but instead boom we
just get this for free by calling a grad
function on this whole thing and it's
going to compute the gradient of all
this stuff just with one function call
so no calculus for you to do and that
lets you train things efficiently and
automatically so how can this possibly
work well it basically boils down to
kind of thinking about structure in the
chain rule all right and hopefully this
will be I think this will be the only
math I show you but hopefully it'll give
you a little bit of intuition about how
this thing that kind of looks
complicated is really just associativity
so associative 'ti to remind you is
where you have a sequence of expressions
that you're sort of composing together
and it's the idea that you know we can
put parentheses around in different ways
and not affect the overall answer so we
have our sort of cat detector that we're
trying to build here and the cat
detector being a neural network is going
to be a composition of little functions
like F and G and H that we're stacking
together and the each of which have a
bunch of parameters and if we compose
functions together and then take their
derivatives right then we're using the
chain rule where we sort of take the
derivative of F and then we multiply
that by the derivative of G and so on
and so if you write that out then you
wind up with with the product of each of
these little derivatives okay and those
are going to be Jacobian so they're big
matrices that have the dimension input
by output okay and now we want to
compute the we want to somehow
efficiently compute the like gradient of
this whole thing okay that looks like it
might be obnoxious there's two kinds of
automatic differentiation there's the
kind you would do if you were like
sitting in your senior year calculus
class where you would say well I'm going
to sort of go left to right and I'm
going to first compute you know I'm
gonna compute this guy's gradient and
I'm gonna multiply by this guy's
gradient and I'm going to just sort of
tick from left to right and apply these
guys together and this is what we might
call forward mode differentiation and
the reason that's kind of potentially
inefficient for things like neural
networks is that it requires a bunch of
matrix multiplies okay so they're kind
of intermediate state here is matrix
matrix multiply by another matrix
multiply another matrix ultimately by a
vector what's the sort of like
computational complexity of matrix
multiplies
it's like naively cubic right so that's
that feels bad that's expensive
the idea of reverse mode automatic
differentiation back propagation
whatever it is no matter how much like
Wired magazine tells you it's flipping
magic it really just boils down to the
fact that you're going to go from right
to left instead and what's the what's
the asymptotic complexity of a matrix
vector multiply this quadratic instead
of cubic and you know for computer
scientists that's a huge win and that's
actually the difference between being
able to do this and not that's the
difference between your phone being able
to take faces and not okay so so we
could just go right to left and compute
derivatives this way and this is what
back propagation is this is what reverse
mode automatic appreciation is this is
what basically tensorflow
or torch or theano or any sort of
package you might have you might
encounter is okay so they're interesting
kind of abstractions for this for doing
both forward and reverse mode where you
write a piece of code and then
automatically get this gradients I'll
kind of gloss over these a little bit
but basically the gist of is just you
things that were numbers before and he
make them little you sort of wrap them
up where you have numbers and the
gradients of those numbers if you were
gonna compute these these gradients
going like left to right then you might
take the the number you get as you're
computing that forward pass and sort of
make a tuple of it with its with the
bits of the chain rule that you were
also accumulating as you're going left
to right this is really great if you
have functions that have large fan-out
so if you have something where you have
a scalar or a small number of parameters
that are governing a very large like
vector field that's not the case so we
have a machine learning we have a
machine learning is instead things that
have a lot of fan in you have a neural
network that's gonna have you know
billions or millions of parameters in it
and it's all gonna squeeze down in a
huge funnel to one scalar that tells you
how well it predicts cats okay
and so what you want to be able to do is
efficiently compute the gradient all
that stuff in terms of that one scalar
right and so the idea of reverse mode
reverse mode automatic differentiation
is that it's a it's also called the
adjoint method we make this forward pass
and then we're going to accumulate at a
a computational tape that you store as
you're doing computations and then when
you can walk back to that tape to
compute the chain rule the point is
though that this makes life really easy
if somebody else has done the work of
implementing that stuff for you did you
don't even have to worry about tapes you
don't have to worry about dual numbers
or on and adjoints and all this kind of
stuff you can using a tool like auto
grad you can just write numb by code
like you might ordinarily and suddenly
gradients pop out of that for free so
who's who writes python probably
everybody you know so you're used to
doing things with with numpy or numpy is
it numb numb PI or numb B PI ok numpy
there we go
and so instead of importing numpy you
import Auto grad numpy and now you you
know you could do whatever you want with
this you can you can you can multiply
matrices you can take eigenvalues you
can do all the kind of stuff that you
you know and love and now when you've
written your functions you instead you
can get gradients of these things for
free which means that anything you can
invent
writing in a forward way in Python you
can train a neural network to do that
essentially okay and and this is
something developed a might this is
something that came out of my group at
Harvard with my student Dougal Maclaurin
and my postdocs Matt Johnson and David
do you know this is something that sort
of so in Python this isn't the fastest
thing in the world but here at Twitter
we realized that this was going to
enable us to build all kinds of crazy
systems like image captioning like like
these kind of these kind of text
classification things that we could
prototype things very very fast if we
never had to do any math right and then
we could come up with crazy
architectures using arbitrarily can
arbitrary control structures if we sort
of were released from the classic ways
of having to come up with little modules
whose whose gradients you need to
compute and so Alex will schoo and Luke
Alonso claim affair Bay developed a
torch verse and so torch is one of the
sort of pillar towards sort of toolkits
for deep learning right now implemented
you know it gives you GPU access kind of
all of the kind of like great hotness of
doing fast steep learning and what they
did is they took these abstractions for
for sort of very general automatic
differentiation and made them work and
work very fast in in torch so the point
is that you can you don't have to think
about these things you could just grab
one of these tools and use all of the
control flow that you like from Python
or Lua and then get its automatically
and one of the things just really cool
about Python autograph which seems kind
of crazy is that not only is it does it
give you gradients for free but it's
closed so you take a gradient and you
can take the gradient of that gradient
and the gradient of that gradient and so
on you you wind up staying within this
space of things who's different you know
on which you can perform differentiation
so if we took that function from before
then we can just like just make function
calls and get new exact differences for
these so this is this is really cool if
you'd like to do second order
optimization that might be a lot faster
than what than sort of the vanilla thing
or we also like to use it for sort of
doing the science of deep learning where
we try to investigate curvature and the
sort of differential geometry of of
different kinds of like optimization
services
so what I thought so I should also point
out I mean this there's a sort of a
spectrum of these packages automatic
is often implemented as a kind of
domain-specific language living inside
something like Python which is what it
looks like if you've played with ten
with tensorflow or Theon oh and I should
say also that this is a big field and
there's there's like places like Auto
difft org that you can check out to
learn a lot more about this stuff and
and also a great recent review paper on
on this as it applies to to machine
learning so what I thought I'd do is
tell you a couple of sort of like little
vignettes of totally crazy things you
can do if you have access to
sufficiently powerful automatic
differentiation I'll just sort of zip
through a couple of these but it's it's
fun to just imagine like crazy stuff so
for example optimizing the optimization
process right so you might apply
stochastic gradient descent to your
neural network to Train it to learn cats
as we discussed before but you might a
lot of questions about you know what's
the right way to set my learning rate
how should i regularization parameters
you might have a lot of sort of things
that you had to set in an ad hoc way but
stochastic gradient descent this
optimization procedure is itself a
composition of a bunch of differentiable
functions so you can actually back
propagate through stochastic gradient
descent to ask what sort of give
yourself a microscope in a sense to ask
questions about how about how these
things might train so for example if
you've trained a neural network then you
might have faced this challenge of
trying to figure out how to set the the
learning rate for the different layers
here where we have access to gradients
we can ask questions like well what
would the what are the right learning
rates not just for every layer or the
whole thing but for every single time
step what if every single time step of
our training had its own unique learning
rate and so you get some interesting
insights about about the fact that the
the final layer tends to want to learn
really aggressively fast in this and the
and the first layer learns a little bit
the whole time but actually kind of the
other layers don't really seem to matter
that much anyway there's two kinds of
questions you can ask that we couldn't
sort of asked before similarly there's
been a lot of intuitions about how to
initialize the like the scale of the
weights in fact it sounds like a really
trivial thing but the difference between
now and 1992 in terms of deep learning
can largely in can be a surprising
amount of the advances can be explained
by realizing that you should think hard
about the initialization of the weights
before you train the network so that is
like what's the standard deviation of
your initialization and there's been
some intuitions that have been developed
that that then it was possible to sort
of rationally rationally verify
similarly you can ask really crazy
questions like what if I demise my
training data like what if instead of
what if I wanted to get build a like
Amnesty and written digit recognizer and
I let it pick and I let it identify ten
data examples so we're going to be the
best ones to improve my validation
performance then like what what training
data would it really like to have and
you can kind of see that it learns some
digits necessarily but kind of funky
digits where they tend to be well
defined where they don't where they
don't overlap with each other you can
also do some totally wild things aren't
machine learning so for example doing
computational fluid dynamics so solving
like implicit Euler equations for like
the navier-stokes to do fluid fluid
simulation that is it solves the
composition of a bunch of differentiable
functions and so you could do something
crazy like you know that scene again in
in Lord of the Rings right where like
Gandalf blows smoke and it turns it to
like a complicated ship or something
well we could like ask the same question
what would be the initial velocities of
like a flow field such that after a
little while the smoke turned into some
object that we get to pick right so what
are we so what we're saying is so take
the Twitter bird and ask the flow field
to land in that spot after a little bit
of simulation and then back propagate
all the way through the flow field and
figure out what the initial velocities
should be from those bands in order to
achieve it right like that's what I'm
saying like you do some crazy stuff if
you have sufficiently powerful automatic
differentiation like kind of ask
questions that you know aren't
necessarily important but are
interesting that said I have been on a
thread with Ferrari about trying to do
this to optimize like ground effect on
their cars right and so there are people
who do care about getting really good at
aerodynamics
other things you can do who's heard of
like variational inference does
something on anybody's radar so often
when you're doing Bayesian Bayesian
modeling you've got to you want to
approximate the posterior distribution
with some simpler distribution this is
called variational variational inference
it is usually sort of like calculus
Laden where the papers you read are just
a bunch of expectations about your
integrals and then taking a bunch of
derivatives automatic differentiation
it's like it's tiny right you just say
I'm gonna approximate some arbitrary log
probability function with a Gaussian
distribution and take its derivative and
optimize it and it's so small that you
can fit it into it you could I can't
actually fit it into 140 characters with
attribution and and just to give you an
idea what this like little piece of code
does if we have some complicated
distribution like this saddle-shaped
thing then the idea is that we could fit
it we can approximate it using a simpler
thing like a Gaussian like a factor
Gaussian distribution okay so that's
kind of the I can do the same kind of
thing with neural networks where again
we're trying to approximate some
possibly very complicated thing and we
could write down it we can write it down
as an objective function where we don't
have to think very hard about about the
math and then the last thing is a
crazier frankly and but also kind of
more exciting these other things are
sort of kind of fun like interest if you
care about things like neural networks
and a Bayesian inference one of the
other things and this is actually some
of the original motivation for this work
it's using there's this emerging area of
trying to use machine learning to design
new materials okay so this is a
collaboration that my group at Harvard
has had with chemists at Harvard and at
MIT and we're actually trying to use
machine learning and deep learning in
particular to predict the properties of
new kinds of molecules so that then we
can we can use that to rationally design
new things to make so the particular
kinds of things we we care about here
are things like organic photovoltaics so
organic photovoltaics so these are solar
cells but made a sort of plastic so
solar cells like the kinds that you
encounter every day are rigid they're
sort of made of silicon type materials
they're very expensive and bulky they
take something like two years to recover
the amount of energy that it took to
create them but in principle we can make
these things out of plastic we had the
right organic materials and then they
could be you could just make them alike
on roll-to-roll printers you can mold
them in all kinds of shapes they can be
transparent
be really great right but we actually
don't know about materials that are
competitive with their rigid
counterparts but we can look for them
and we can try to model their properties
and invent new ones and then and then
another kind of analogous material
instead of instead of solar cells is
organic LEDs where you're trying to
design display devices that can be
flexible and made of plastic and have
all the same kind of properties and be
super cheap so that you know you could
have a television there it's just like a
poster on the wall okay so what we're
gonna do is try to build big neural
networks that look at the structure of
molecules and try to predict their
properties like how bright it's going to
be if it's an LED or how efficient it
would be if it was a photovoltaic and
then with our collaboration with these
chemists actually synthesize them and
actually turn them into devices and
evaluate their performance and so by
having very powerful automatic
differentiation we were able to look at
data that is kind of out of the scope
for like image based methods and the
kind of stuff that you see you know
coming out of places talking about like
for visual object recognition and speech
recognition and things like that where
we can actually create complicated
convolutional neural networks that are
embedded on the graph and then sort of
learn about molecular structure in order
to make predictions about about these
molecules and it turns out that this is
a highly effective thing to do and has
given us sort of state-of-the-art
performance on a variety of things like
you know detecting toxicity signing new
you know in predicting again the
properties of things like organic
photovoltaics it also has kind of
interesting properties that learns about
things that chemists seem to know about
so for example trying to predict you can
sort of interrogate the neural network
to ask it about what it knows about
solubility after you train it and I'm
not a chemist but even I can kind of
tell that the stuff on the left here is
polarized it's gonna tend to tend to be
soluble in the stuff on the right here
it's not going to be you can also it can
also identify sub structures that tend
to to lead to toxic materials the point
is overall the weekend it kind of allows
you to unlock creativity it's it's a
tool that automates enough of this
process that you can get down to the
business of modeling coming up with
architectures and sort of doing science
and building new products and so I think
it's a very exciting sort of sort of
time for this where it's really come of
age it's been an idea people have
thought about for a long time
now there's like tools you can just like
pip install and and be going right away
so these are some different github links
for both Python autograph but also
Twitter's torch out or grad and some of
these other things I mentioned as well
so I'll stop there thank you very much